[Music]
samuel leeds is britain's most notorious
multi-millionaire property investor
best-selling author and founder of a
leading property education company
with hundreds of success students
carving their way to financial freedom
using his cutting-edge strategies
samuel is regarded as the ultimate
renegade property investor
in this year's eviction the stakes have
been raised big time
with the winner receiving the keys to
the kingdom by getting a life-changing
prize
of a whole week's one-to-one mentoring
in their own financial freedom challenge
more drama more heartbreak and more
action
as candidates battle it out to be the
2020 winner of
the eviction we had over 500 people
applied to be on the eviction
man we've got 10 candidates that are
part of the process
let's see what happens this is crazy
you're evicted
i didn't want sympathy i didn't want
people to be like oh you know
you'll find another job you know i
didn't want help
i wanted to be left alone because i knew
that there was another way wow
i think this is it i've been praying for
this for a long time to become somebody
to inspire individuals and
when i actually saw what's possible in
property
i was just like completely blown away
and super excited always my dream was
property
and it wasn't my thing to go and work
for somebody i wanted to be
my own boss if i could move home do
properties full time in northern ireland
i could stay home be with my family
and finally after traveling since 2013
so this is it decision time is very very
close
i'm about to decide who i'm going to be
spending a week with
doing the financial freedom challenge
with them i've told the three
contestants
to come and meet me at my castle i'm
going to put them through some severe
training i'm going to introduce them to
some of my savage
business associates who are going to be
going over their business plans
and then i'm going to be bringing the
three of them right here
in my boardroom at my house and making
my final decision
we're on our way to meet evans at his
actual house
amanda what do you think of evans you've
been seeing what's what yeah
um he seems really confident and he's
like
very openly saying like he's that he's
gonna win
so i don't know whether that's like
whether that makes me want him to win
more
or all the opposite effect i'm
interested to see
if he actually is gonna is
actually gonna win because he talks a
big game yeah
but but the thing is he talks a big game
is he just confident and he talks a big
game but also
he's a good player or i guess we're
gonna find out now
if he's blagged his way to the finals or
if he actually deserves to be here we'll
find but i think i think you'll become
apparent today
thank you so much
you've got the whole family bro though
how are you doing good to meet you hello
are you proud of him
i am when we found out he was coming on
the show we were screaming like we were
so excited they were like watching tv in
here we were on the stairs
so yeah no we're so so excited amazing
yeah well you've had a job you meant to
start a new job but he obviously turned
it down for the shows
we're not gonna let anything get in the
way so talk to me a little bit about
your
your back story when did you move to the
uk
talk to me a little bit about how you
even kind of
ended up here um i came to the uk in
2015 august 21 it's about seven years
ago initially i came here i believe in
20
in 20 in 2009 um i came to play football
i came to playstation professional
football but um i got
injuries that didn't really work out
long story short um i know it's like i
end up going to work on a cruise ship
because a friend of mine
it's like if you go walk on the cruise
ship um there's opportunities there
there's people from all parts of the
world you can meet them
who knows what can happen so i went to
work on the cruise ship um i was just
doing um just a bad boy nothing special
um making like next to nothing um
another i met uh i met somebody
um and obviously i came to the uk in
2015.
and um yeah i came with nothing started
the board stuck in shelves
i didn't really have nothing my family
didn't really contribute that much
i worked my way up i started looking at
your car park stuck in shops i move up
to
car giants um selling cars i never saw a
car in my life
but the second month after i started
working there i was the the
best sales executive out of a hundred
from there i was obviously you know i
had a kid my son jayla you just met
and i was very stressed for that i'm
making a lot of money but i never had
time
so what happened from there i
transitioned to working at range rover
dealership
um that's a bit with my partner ellen um
so then i was making good money uh
driving a range rover
and it really just um working there
really changed me as an individual
because i came in here humble and hungry
but when i started working at range
rover
i became very comfortable making a lot
of money became very cocky
i didn't like the person i was and um i
i found network marketing
and i think network marketing is what
really changed my life around i met
another marketing and um
i just really just saw my job completely
differently put it that way
it didn't really work out so i just
completely left my job do network
marketing full time
but like two months into my into my
progress uh my team kind of like left
because my team lead up
he left he went to another company so
like my entire team
left me like my income stops i had a
mortgage pending i didn't know what to
do
but one good thing that came out of that
is obviously i was at my lowest i was
tripped and i thank god for that because
obviously it really brought me back to
the person i was when i came back so i
wasn't
i lost all my ego um and very people
stood around me and obviously that's the
reason why i'm with ellen because um
you know i was very very down and she
was the one one of the only people that
was there for me
plus i lost i lost 22 kg in um in about
a month and a half
wow and um and then obviously you know i
saw your videos your videos really
instilled belief in me
um i started watching your videos i'm
like you know what it is i have to get
it after getting the property
i just saw your video um to apply for
the eviction i applied for the eviction
i wanted to get in but i was just like
you know things have been going wrong
one after the other so i wouldn't be
surprised that i don't get in
and then i got it i'm just like wow like
i think this is it i've been praying for
this for a long time
i went with the eviction and and the
first day i came in i was like you know
what it is this is it i've been praying
for this you know i write down
my affirmations every single day to
become somebody to inspire individuals
and
when i actually saw what's possible in
property
i just like completely blown away and
super excited
[Music]
good to meet you thanks you've got a
great family thank you and i look
forward to seeing you next week
cool take care see you get that business
plan you're welcome guys thank you so
much
two minutes from lorton's house this is
very much what i expected by the way
yeah of what lawton's area would be like
it feels nice
i know what you mean he's come across
very well presented
seems quite well off i think as well
actually it'll be interesting to see
to hear a story and to see like what
this means to him
his reason why and like whether this is
like
make or break like does he really really
need it i know he's been doing property
he says for a couple months
back in my videos but he seems
experienced
by his parents in property are they
going to inherit him a big portfolio
anyway
does he need this that's the question
very nice
so it's funny lawton the champion of all
the challenges and this is his home
i think it is like if he's got money
that's cool i'm not gonna be like you're
really rich therefore it's gonna hinder
you in the
but it just kind of begs the question
why would he need
the eviction why wouldn't he just pay
for the training right what's happening
hello rachel how are you doing
hey guys great to meet you it's a
beautiful house
it's almost a bit too beautiful i mean
if i'm going to be really honest with
you i'm kind of thinking
it's such you you laughton i've got it
all together
you've got a beautiful partner you've
got a wonderful son you're living in
this big
nice house i kind of just think um
like i don't know i mean you kind of
almost seem to have made it a little bit
i don't know what do you think about
that i mean like we've i've worked hard
all throughout my life
on the surface it might look like i've
made it or
you know we've got all of our ducks in a
row but in actual fact we haven't
you know life is a struggle and anyone
who knows you know i'm 32 i've had
many different jobs i've been a plumbing
heating engineer by trade i've
worked at british gas you know i've
slowly climbed that corporate ladder
moved into account management and senior
account management but
you know that got poured from under our
feet you know i was made redundant in
july of this year because of you know
covered you know lockdown when this
happened
i was like this is bad
like this is bad my salary wouldn't
cover the
the mortgage and the bills yeah i had a
good job in a company car
you know as as your living expense goes
up because you your
salary goes up you know that was taken
away and then i'm left with this that
i've got to make every month
and there had to be um another way out
watching your videos
allowed me to learn deal sourcing rachel
you um
you said that you were obviously really
supportive of stuff but you've also got
a little bit of skepticalness there
is that fair to say i was because we've
you know we lived with my mum while
we're staying for the house the reason
why i didn't have another child is we
couldn't wouldn't have the money to have
another child
and then we moved here and then you got
made redundant and all i could think of
is
how we're going to pay the mortgage so i
was like you need to get another job
you have to go and get another job i
have sleepless nights we have had that
let's come through the door haven't we
is that fair to say yes
we've had that last come through the
door how we're going to pay our bills
and then you started watching videos of
how to do property sourcing
and i'd say it's only the past month
where i felt
you know that this might be a good
school it's going in the right direction
so we can do the things that we we want
to do you've gone from jobs to job
um and you know things haven't gone well
and
you know i just i just want him to do
well now i just wanted to have that
break
you know when we had our son we weren't
together that long i felt pregnant
quite quickly and then we thought what
what what did we do
like what do we do so my mum and my dad
said you can come and live with us
you were in and out of jobs at the time
weren't you like it was
it was really difficult and we just
saved it took us six years to save
six years of times where we didn't do
anything we didn't go out we didn't do
anything at all
and then the day that we got the keys to
this house it's like we've done it we've
done on our own we had no help from them
inevitably
didn't know when he was good the most
coming at the end of that month and
i i didn't have the money and i refused
to tell
anybody that i've been made redundant
even today
like my dad doesn't know my mum doesn't
know
your parents don't know i didn't want
sympathy i didn't want people to be like
oh you know you'll find another job
you know i didn't want help i wanted to
be left alone because i knew that there
was another way
[Music]
all right see you soon guys
been an interesting few days so we've
had london to begin with with evans
and then i was brought to manchester by
lawton they were both fantastic
um david is from northern ireland and
wants to do the challenge in northern
ireland so
i'm about to go to his house right now
and i think david is
solid i really like him my only fear
with david
is i just don't know whether he's gonna
be able to take the pressure
of a financial freedom challenge i don't
know whether he's gonna be
the kind of person that might melt under
that kind of pressure i don't know he's
not
got the same aggression and the same
fire
certainly outwardly that the other boys
have got but we'll find out now and i'm
gonna push him and let's see what he
says hey david how you doing
nice to see you it's very hard to find
yeah it was really hard to find but
we'll go here in the end thank you very
much
i'm keeping good hello stuff so uh
i'm really excited to get to get to know
you and have a chat afford nowhere like
this
i just rent an annex so
is so small okay so show me shall we
show it around oh well they've lived
with us actually for nearly
nearly four years and we're very very
fond of them
yes they're they're very well they're
very respectful
of i mean they've only got a small place
in there but they're very respectful of
it
they keep it very deep and tidy and
clean
in fact we're thinking of charging
debbie for a new hoover
she's wearing the one out for four years
we we haven't found one fault
in them this is all
i have basically okay it's you've been
like the second visitor
ever seems like a nice place i think it
works out well
it's 22 of us and you know it's me and
my partner
yes of course david's going to win the
eviction and he's dedicated determined
he really wants to do it
loves property and and he's just been
the happiest he's ever been
i really think that you're going to win
the election
hopefully this is this is life-changing
you know
i want to do it so i think we can so
in terms of your situation right now
you told me that your home is island
yeah so i thought i might be having to
come to ireland
but then it turns out that your home is
ireland but you're living
in a bed set in um in the south east
in england so why are you living in
england
but then you say your home is ireland
what's this what's the situation uh
iron it's jobs there's no jobs at all
we're deprived of
opportunities so just move to the south
east of england got a job in
construction
and that's we just settled here for now
but
i would love to go back to ireland but
just unfortunately
there is no work there any job that
opens any business there's
they're inundated with applicants they
have to stop so there's a chip shop
job looking just to wash all the dishes
and there was over 400 applicants
wow so they had to actually stop with
that so
that's a competition you're up against
so what's the dream
then over the next six to 12 months to
move home the dream is told
if i could move home do properties full
time
in northern ireland i could stay home be
with my family
and finally after traveling since 2013
i just make you to go home so always my
dream is property
and it wasn't my thing to go and work
for somebody
i wanted to be my own boss and
definitely school it's not
how how old are you now 30 just turned
sir
so you say you left you left school what
like 16.
yes 17. love's got 17. property's always
been your dream
yeah why have you not done anything over
the last 13 years it's
it's hard like it's i haven't got the
call the education or the qualifications
to go on myself do my own business
so i think we're just going to do
anything just for the money aspect
so i got under construction and
i had to move to england to get to work
but then my money is forked out on rent
and you know it's we can't really make
the money that
what we could do in property and the
lack of the education
until i came across you so at the moment
i'm actually unemployed but my partner
is employed
as a school office administrator and
i i'm kind of in between the middle if i
move home i'm going to take my partner
out of a job
and if we both move home together she's
unfortunately going to have no work
so it's quite a difficult situation to
be in at the minute
probably came from the hardest
background and now
this is going to be changing if i won
this i finally got to move home
is this is this is your business
this uh this we can forget
you you need to write a brand new
business plan which actually
which actually is about you the goal
welcome back to my home you've had a
week now to put together your business
plans
and i'm joined by my business associates
and close friends
jl spooner gel was my very first student
and since then she's grown to grow a
large property portfolio she's
financially free
one of her commercial properties turns
over a million pounds a year
russell leeds russell's my brother also
ceo over our company
self-made millionaire and alastair
cunningham
hard-nosed scott he's got the largest
property sourcing company in the uk
they've all been over your business
plans they've got some questions to ask
you in the house
then it's going to be for me decision
time of who is going to be the winner
of 2020 eviction so follow me through
the house
hello hello have you brought your
business partner i have
awesome i'll give you guys one that
would be great
your goal your personal goal is to have
a business
that gives you enough profit you can pay
yourself a salary
of passing with 2450 pounds correct got
it okay
makes sense uh give you more time
yourself etc okay cool that was
a big point two to feed that
so points you said to complete and build
my mom's house in saluta
yeah yeah uh mommy has uh hold on
i've never heard the word mommy referred
to a business plan
okay do you think that's professional um
probably not okay i get you love your
mom
i get it but it doesn't to me it doesn't
scream
professional it screams like it's like a
five-year-old's writing a business plan
like he's just made it up on the spot
mommy's doing this mommy used to come on
man it's not professional
if you want to be treated like
professional you need to act like a
professional
correct okay you know the thing is a
jail that this
this whole thing confused me cool
i i i'm pretty good to understand the
business plans yeah
but this i have no idea what you even
planned to do you tell us yeah
what is your plan in a nutshell don't
walk alone i don't want a story i just
wanna
a bullet point what are you gonna do in
the next one to twelve months two
uh twelve months twenty four months and
then whatever else after that in a
nutshell
do you want a copy of this to go to
because this this
i wouldn't even read this if you come to
me and say it
else i've got a few because from it i
would take one look at it
rip it up and just say you're not even
watching business with
so explain to me why we should do
business with you
absolutely well look first things first
i'm never going to lose this one before
that's an excuse i don't want to hear it
fantastic so my problem with the next
part is six months since the
situation was okay one to twelve months
what even though one to twelve and i'm
gonna be doing the rents the rental
vision wasn't your source okay how are
you gonna find that
i'm gonna fund it yeah you're sourcing i
don't need anything
so one to twelve months you say you're
gonna be rent to around and deal so much
how much money are you going to carry
over from year one to year two so
four thousand pounds exactly that's how
much you're going to turn over
yes and so how and how much are you
gonna take a salary so
uh so it's one day the first page
2400 a month okay so eight four thousand
takes
1400 a month you just have little
figures i mean
the figures are very much made up eighty
four thousand pounds
uh but it is 94. okay so whatever you've
put down you put down 84 000.
so how much salary are you gonna take a
month honestly speaking
i i will not take any salary um because
i don't really need
a salary that money is just to obviously
build work people why intensive bills
but what i've poor one day is my
financial freedom target of 24.50
but are you going to use this actually
four grand yeah it's actually more but
we'll go there for
four grand are you going to keep
all of that to reinvest or you'll be
taking that out so i've been taking some
of it
and uh i've put how much about half of
it
about the heart for 2 000. yeah so wait
so now we're at 42 000. what are you
doing
i'm just going to keep it there to
obviously to find my big will i think
why is that right in here
what's that sorry why have you not put
in here what are you going to do
with that man yeah because this is your
business plan and you've got this money
sitting in your business plan yeah
and you've just completely discounted it
but not told what you're going to do
well on this page 13 put into 24 months
yeah i have put that i'm going to use jv
partners
and i'm going to use the money rate from
year 1 to fund my buyer for this
refinance
doesn't qualify all you said is i'm
going to raise jv partners one you're
not qualified
quantified how are you going to raise jv
partners and the second reason is you
should
use funds raised from year one but again
you understand how much that's going to
be
so if you want to take a salary over you
need to doubt that if you want to take
course running course maintenance all
sorts of stuff you're not allowed for
any of that
so you're factoring in that you're gonna
make 100 profit from all the properties
that's just not realistic at all the
other thing is is that normally a
business plan is designed if you want to
get someone to invest in your let's say
you go to the bank and you want to look
this is my plan so i'm going to do that
they would laugh you out
yeah they wouldn't even meet with you
you wouldn't be taken seriously
the thing is i mean obviously we haven't
been really following um
we'll have to watch the show so
in the real world you've been doing
brilliantly so i think that the lesson
for you here is if you want to attract
for example jd partners
you need to be able to take that
brilliance that you've got
and put it on that because they're
they're not gonna they're not gonna be
following you around
you can't listen saying oh i mean
obviously you're playing them blogging
it
but you're gonna be happy to go to them
with proposals
and if you take a proposal like this
that you're not going to get any money
out of anyone i'll tell you no i've
raised finance
and you have got not a hoping hills
chance of reason finance for this
um i'll use uh i want
i will use a one brings two strategy to
do so
which means i will attract a minimum of
five sources a month for using marketing
and networking
which will bring a minimum of one source
by encouraging them to attractive cone
dual sources i don't know what that
means
i actually respect the tenacity in you
and i actually see
so much of myself in you okay i know how
hard it can be when you
find it hard to put numbers and words
and things together
trust me i know okay i have to deal with
it every day
all right it's not easy i get that and
what's the advantage that we have
is we're so tenacious and we're
visionaries and we can see it we know it
can happen
and we will give everything we can to
physically
make it happen and trust me you're going
to succeed
okay because what you have inside of you
that light that you have that drive that
vision those dreams they're going to
come
true because you believe them and you
won't stop until it happens
read a book educate yourself
do the courses watch the youtube clips
right send me about any emails you have
to send to state agencies
so many emails you have to send out if i
sent all my emails to my architects and
my power team and i didn't have the
right numbers
if i said return investment sheets to
samuel i didn't have the right numbers
the right spelling do you think it's
going to take me seriously do you think
any of my team are going to take me
seriously
no you have to learn this part you
can't skip it i know it's hard but you
can't skip it you have to learn it
that's it
tough good it's very happy but it's uh
it's just definitely white lid
[Music]
was you instructed to do that was you
instructed to put the personal goals in
the plan
yeah i can remember right so you don't
remember being
requested to put the personal plans in
it
you apologize for that
why don't you tell us about your
personal goals anyway so my personal
goals are to become
financially free then become ultimately
financially free
and then i do want to teach so i want to
use my personal experiences to show
everybody else that there is another way
rather than doing the corporate life
because for myself my back stories that
i try to
corporate life and works up to a senior
accountant which for me
was incredibly hard especially within my
family
and then that rug got pulled from
underneath my feet and in lockdown i was
made redundant
so sure how are you going to become
financially free what was your what was
the actual goals that you put
so in terms of financing three i was
looking at
the deal sourcing company and
my roadmaps for the next 12 months how
many deals i'm going to be doing to me
you've wrote nothing here yes
i've made a table
um
business have you ever started so i've
already started it and i called you
source at a minute
cool all right so let's take a look so
that's what you've done so far
but you've obviously shown that you've
got the ability to go and find deals yes
that's good for this month to plan on
using my spend money that i made from
my biggest month last month to actually
go compliant
but then decided to take that money to
not be compliant and then
offering a unique turnkey investment how
is it unique
so in terms of my experiences becoming
an engineer and working in the
construction industry what i also offer
as an optional
extra is a project management fee so in
terms of refurbished finance
i can use my bills and my contacts
within the industry to have the
property refurbished and i will project
money but that's not unique
it is compared to some of the ones i've
spoken to that's not unique that means
nobody's done it before
i've been doing this for three years
i've been off on project management
three years so it's not how is it i
don't understand well for me
for me it feels like it's unique
considering i've only been doing it
eight weeks
so i don't know every business that's
out there don't know all the competitors
[Music]
management also which i've learned today
so there's definitely all the businesses
that i need to learn from
but do not think that if you're looking
to do deal sourcing you would find
somebody who's doing it
look at their business model one and
then take it from there
so have you have you sold um
have you actually sold that service yeah
so you've managed the project
yeah it wasn't a great probably i think
it's like 250 grit
it was only a small refurb okay how'd
that go really well actually
i think before you can say something is
a unique bespoke
yeah you have to make sure because
obviously you know you're putting
together a website if you're telling
people what you're doing
they're gonna you're gonna lose
customers if they feel that you're
saying it's a unique
experience but they've also had those
experiences with other deal sources
so definitely there's a lack here of
research which i think is
really really important at this point
to have do you know what it screams to
me right what's the most important thing
about deal sourcing
finding great deals no credibility
okay if you want to be able to sell to
investors you need to have credibility
now if their first point of contact with
yourself is you say this is a unique
service
and they know it's not they've already
switched off from you because
they think you're you're bs in them yeah
that's the problem okay so credibility
will just you lose credibility so be
very careful words are powerful
can you see why um it's hard for us
to understand this because i mean
obviously you've written the description
here but then when we're asking you
questions you've got all these different
strategies
you haven't led us to that yeah you
haven't demonstrated to us how you're
actually going to achieve this yes
that's my experience in writing business
funds i completely agree with
that i mean how long does it take you to
put this uh business plan together
probably a couple of days a couple of
days so you could have you really could
have just used a couple of more to have
given it
you know given it your all you know
you're here um
in front of great people with great
opportunity um
i just feel like you could have just
given us you know
50 percent more you know and really have
just
gone through a fine tooth cold exactly
how
you plan to run your business because at
the end of the day you might
feel like this is a business plan for us
to just skim through
but actually this is something that you
could file and put on your shelf
i still have my business plan it's got
you know hardback
you know and it's filed and i know that
i can always go back to it
if i need it and that's kind of what we
wanted to see
for me this is a more of an over over
elaborate explanation of
what you're trying to do it's not a
business man
i get this i get this right but
some of it is ridiculous and i don't
i don't get how you can stand there and
say this sort of stuff like for instance
right
um you're gonna charge two and a half
thousand times per deal yeah that's a
million dollars
yeah okay then on the land development
side of sourcing
what experience have you got source and
land uh not too much so not
on the land development solar side
you're gonna charge three percent of the
total price of the sale and then again
an optional management of ten percent
like what what qualifies you to even say
i can charge 10
it's ridiculous once our investors list
is going to 300 people
you're going to be offering a vip list
to our investors who receive the email
the day before
and they get a first refusal of the
investment fee 150 pounds a month
am i reading things wrong here or is
this just pie in the sky
how much do you charge for yours 24.99 a
month all right that's my
experience again i've only been doing
this for eight weeks 150 pound a month
credibility out of the water yeah okay
next we're going to be doing bespoke
deal source where we give the exact same
property that suits
the criteria the criteria strategy that
investors interested in
for an upfront fee of three thousand
pounds so you're gonna charge them three
thousand pounds
for bespoke social media up front
you've got no credibility to even say
that i've been doing this three four
years
and i just know if anyone's doing smoke
source i charge a thousand pound up
front
and then i charge them the fee at the
end right right so that's my own
experience i think
i thought that you charged up front but
this is we're leveling up
in life right now and you've got you
know you're
working with a great team right now
do you know i was expecting you to
dominate this whole yeah me too
i really was i was expecting you to come
in
and do amazing things and do really well
quite frankly i'm now worrying about
that
i'm not worried if you've even got the
credibility to do this business
because you've not even done the basic
research yeah yeah
the judges were fair i mean the room
definitely flaws in my plan i've never
written a business plan before and it
was just an experience
and i've taken those criticisms on board
i'm going to amend my business plan
and some i'm going to use it as a
reference to look at into the future
thank you very much
okay in a nutshell 10 minute business
planners this has been
broken energy five steps number one i'm
going to raise 6000 phone
sex open phones from this calendar three
rental rents which
at what you're going to give me a
passive income
you're still gonna raise six thousand
pounds
sorry did you say you're gonna raise so
let's tell three deeds so
george trudy so step one sell two deals
yeah we're just going to
two days of three thousand ponies we're
just going to give me six seven pound
the six seven points gonna go on the
step two which is going to give me three
round durants
which will give me a passive income then
step
three is my i'm going to secure three
leash option agreements so they're going
to give me a little bit of power i'm
going to
come with capital appreciation and then
the step forward my biggest plan that is
i referred refinance reach six thousand
pound housing do that
sale truly have you ever sold a deal
before
not not only fixing yes but prior to
that no
so i didn't do any networking but what
i've learned
from this whole process is to be
persistent and get
networking so now you know that's what i
wasn't doing before i've done the
training but
i never actually went you know done the
network and now you know that's where my
flaw was all along so
right okay so you don't know if you can
sell a deal
yes right now yeah because you've never
done it before
so um how long did you vision
it would take you to get the six
thousand pounds you know uh
on the second uh on the infection i had
to show
two days to see me twice for eight
thousand two hundred and fifty
and the only reason i've done that i
knew i was persistent
because before when i was making the
calls if they said no
i was not following up i was bringing
more people
and just putting myself out there and i
actually did
sell the data yeah right yes
i'm more interested in this okay so you
said you're gonna you rate it you wanna
read six thousand pounds
yes then start rent to rent yes okay
so okay so you're then gonna um package
yourself two deals for six thousand one
and then you're gonna
secure three rent to any hmo's at six
thousand pounds that's two thousand
pounds each yes
do you think that's that's that's viable
100 because if you look
i left in comparable seconds occurred
seven bit hmo
for a thousand pounds for 75 pounds per
room
so where can you make them the northern
ireland
so you want to do all of this enormous
islands everything i've got a plan
that's all good
questions yes so my main goal in life is
to move home to ireland that's my party
i'll be a franchisee i want to build
a house in ireland yes uh my mom isn't
going to be at home
look at my parents friends uh but
unfortunately you can't due to financial
circumstances you're trying to support
your family give them freedom so
basically it's all about moving violence
but my goal is i've been away eight
years and it's hard and i want to go
home
just right beside northern ireland it's
about 20 minutes so my
[Music]
employment rate is so high and the
progress is so
cheap and if you can look at the
comparables the rentals quite high
so what's your job right now i'm
unemployed
you're unemployed yes
now you're in ireland what does life
look like for you
now for the passive income now i i can
actually move on out to my next step and
start scanning my business
i finally get to go home why is it so
important for you to go back to normal
that's amazing everyone wants to go home
because that's where i want to be beside
family
i i want to go home what worries me is
if you're not in the environment
if you're not around us kicking your ass
you're going to go back to just sitting
the home behind his wallet
i promise because i i don't see it
because i don't believe it's deep enough
for you
it's up to me to prove i i will not but
i've learned here not
coming back 100 percent i'm going to be
here
and i love that i feel like you've
you've been inspired by this
whole amazing movement that's been taken
place by samuel leeds you know
um and you've been really inspired by
the fact that you can
sell property anywhere you can buy a
property anywhere you can own
property anywhere and that's great we
want you to have that
spark you've been cool sourcing through
my company for how many months
uh nearly six months yeah
oh yes yeah never six months i just
remembered this yes
i've sold none no no so with no pressure
you sold no deals
with somebody who's got the biggest
investor list in the uk yeah and you've
done nothing
look i'm gonna say something i i think
that this whole thing
is quite weak and i i do doubt your
your your ability to win this
competition
if you don't have someone by your side
are you going to achieve this well it
was horrible stand in front of three
like entrepreneurs just getting ripped
apart
could have went a lot better and you
know it's hard to face the music and
whatever they do say it is constructive
criticism so you have to take it on
board and just
put it into our future plan so welcome
back to the board room
it's decision time i'm going to be
really honest
and that's i spoke to russell jl
alastair my business associates and
i have got genuine concerns
about all about all three of you i'm
happy to share what they are and give
you a chance to
you know explain um i mean lawton i
spent half a day with you last week
and came to your house and told you i
wanted three things i wanted your
personal goals written down
i wanted your financial um targets and i
wanted your
your strategies to get there and you
just completely missed out
your personal goals which was really
important
that was a third of the challenge just
you know not done and then david
like a dependable ditherer and all three
of them were like
i don't know how are you going to jail
with david he's a procrastinator
he said he's doing really good on some
of the challenges don't get me wrong
and then evans your business plan was
just a mess
um and they weren't impressed
this isn't something that i want like i
don't want to do this
like i need this this is completely
different
like my work rate since the beginning of
this whole process has been another
level that i've
even learned a lot about myself and how
i conduct myself
in terms of the challenges like i've
given 110
genuinely believe that there isn't a
single person here
that's as hungry as i am for this talk
to me about the about the plan
about just skipping the personal goals
when that was i did i did tell you that
didn't i yeah you know it's quite clear
there was three parts
but both the other the other two put it
in
it kind of shocked me a little bit what
happened i just completely missed it off
i think
never writing a business plan before um
i overwhelmed myself in
in what was needed but that's why i came
around your house i just said look
i just want to see three things your
personal goals your strategies
and your financial targets that's what i
want to say and you didn't bring your
personal goals
and you had a week you had a week to do
it and you spent two days on it
it just doesn't can you can you see well
that looks bad
i can definitely say i haven't
multiplied yet so why should i choose
you
when you haven't even bothered to do
that over these guys that did
and and they're clearly really hungry
and did the business plan for like what
why should i like because every single
challenge on this process i have
completed
but now we're in the finals we're
talking about the final challenge so
and you messed up within this but i
think that even on the financial freedom
challenge
i will be the one that will be able to
do it
with you and keep up with you at your
pace i won't be someone who you'll be
holding their hand and saying
we need to go and do this and he's gonna
do that i will be offering ideas and
alternatives
for you as well like we will do this
together okay evans
talk to me so uh so i really messed up
on the business plan
you know i had a week to do it so you
know i can't make any excuses i should
have googled it
what i can obviously do is that so now
you're just kind of explaining to me and
justifying to me and telling me why i
shouldn't
you shouldn't win this and what i'm
asking you is what you should why should
i come
and move into your house for a week and
do the financial freedom challenge with
you
that's a very good question two things
number one normally i need a good answer
right now absolutely give you a good
answer
no one here wants this to work as bad as
i wanted to work and i can prove that
you see on the last challenge for
example i i walked into the last
challenge thinking a lot on
my biggest competitor yeah and then i
heard lauten made a few comments and i'm
just like
i like this guy is not competitor you
know saying things such as
um you know i can't believe samuel has
renovated
a house for him for free and i was just
sitting there thinking like
how can you actually say that about the
two like it was the biggest opportunity
of our lives
and i'm not just making that i mean
david obviously you know you know very
and obviously when it comes to david
david has been a great competitor
it's just again when it comes to you
know carrying things in david speaker
you know david was worried about you
know getting the carpets you know
painted and stuff like that
and i'm just thinking like this can
change our lives around why would you
care
about something as little as getting the
carpet today and i had a small little
mercedes a class i put a counter in
there
you know free countertops in there i put
a washing machine in there no one stayed
up all night the last night
i noticed everything i've got i was the
only one who started one like give
everything i have
the night prior to that i was the only
one who stayed up and everyone was
sleeping
taking off every single carpet in the
house so by far
in this last depiction like you know
there's no bamboozling there's no
cameraman
the fact of the matter like who you know
with everybody else my definition i
still know
um a little bit help from you i feel
like
this can really change everything around
i think i you're right about david
being a dealer i don't know how you feel
about that david that's just the spread
of people's perspective of me
just because i'm the least focal
attitude i have shown consistency
through every challenge
yeah and there i expected everyone
thought i was going to be the weakest
and it wasn't and i'm sure if he asked
the truth and they would admit i was not
the weakest
and were you the strongest i do i feel
it was the strongest
don't even you don't even sound
convinced in yourself no i do how can i
be convinced in you and i said are you
the strongest leader
i think i will no i haven't done the
fourth signs first there's no
electricity so i
went me and not a move ourselves to say
that right we need to get a generator
i'm the next door and good connected to
the electricity
i connected the electricity with the
plumbing sorted
and then to get to my step two and
that's my favorite today
we'll do the financial freedom challenge
yeah be fantastic yeah sell some deals
we'll get some rental rents then i'll
leave
and then the pressure's off yeah and
then suddenly you'll mess it down no i
disagree because people
they always have that opinion me if
samuel leaves you're gonna cut off it's
not gonna happen
okay this is life changing okay well
listen i wanna just take a moment to
just process what you've said
i'll come back and then i'll give you
one final opportunity to speak and then
i'm gonna make my decision
of who i'm gonna do the financial
freedom challenge with okay i'll back a
few moments
thank you
and you'll do anything for it after you
remember
probably you probably wouldn't have so
how
[Music]
i think you would have gone to bed
earlier if you didn't have to take the
workshops back which you failed to
mention
[Music]
[Music]
it was an absolute
[Music]
i can't believe
phone that shows that that kitchen is
not finished if you're happy enough for
tenancy moving you should not be a
proper investor okay
listen now you're on with the budget
it's been on time yeah that would have
only for me and laughing took that part
yeah because i asked for receipts
okay fantastic
[Music]
because you spent so much time taking
stuff back to being cute that we didn't
need okay
if you hadn't done that you would have
had more time all right
i love the passion it's it's good um
diff slightly different stories you can
see why it's a tough tough challenge for
me
i just want to say make it really clear
regardless of what happens tonight
every single one of you can leave with
your head held high thank you
every single one of you can go with your
head held high um i'm going to give you
one final opportunity uh evans
why should i do the financial freedom
challenge with you
because samuel i have through i'm an
action taker yeah
and i know obviously you know you know
physically putting money into
into giving us the prize money but
you're giving us a lot more than that
you're giving us the stage of where so
you can obviously speak in
you know almost thousands around the
world
and by far i'm going to give you the
return on your investment not just based
on what i'm going to say to you
but based on what i've done you see some
you know some people obviously the
camera people
and they know how to bamboozle their way
past things but i think at the end of
the day in the final
it's all down to action like what can
you bring to the table i have obviously
surpassed in the last challenge
my actions obviously were louder than
everybody else and that's exactly what
i'm going to bring to the financial
freedom challenge to give me
opportunities
okay so everyone
started preparing me before the
challenges david's not going to do this
i have proved it all along i will do it
you know i sold these deals
and this means motivating everything
this is life-changing whatever
whatever you say changed my life because
i can move home i'm going to date
like all the knowledge you give me right
through from the academy
to the affection and you put me onto
that intensity and i'm not going to drop
these levels so
whatever happens today regardless i'm
going to be successful
and that's just thankful really
you've changed why why are you a
stronger candidate than launching the
women's i feel overall i've proved
myself getting better and better and
they if they've been honest they've they
know that i've grown
right through this why are you stronger
than logan because i feel overall that
i'm a better
team player okay and put me on the
pressure i have mob trumps every time
and i've proved people wrong i think
since it was the least focal i've always
been
looked down since i started fixing and
now i think this last challenge with the
reefer
actually shows that i get the work done
yeah i can work to a budget i'm a team
player
okay this is what i want lawson same
question
i need this more than everybody because
at the minute i do not have a job
i am full time in property since i've
been made redundant your training has
allowed me to earn
some money to pay my bills ever since i
need this to spring box my business
forward so i can look after my family
myself
and then grow my business i am the most
hardworking person here
from day one every single challenge i
have completed it i have worked the
hardest
i've put in more than 110 effort into
every single challenge that i've ever
had
so i know that by picking me the
freedom financial challenge will be
amazing you know it's a big decision for
me because a week is a long time right
um a very very very long time i have
made my decision
and there's i'm i'm going to tell you
and my decision is final
i am going to be spending all week doing
the financial freedom challenge
congratulations i've also
made a slight another decision as well
on top of that
and that is that i'm also going to do a
financial freedom challenge
as well with laughton
and i'm just feeling crazy but i'm going
to do one with evans as well
[Applause]
now i'm raising the bar right now
welcome i'm raising the bar right now
massively here's how this is going to
roll
okay we're going to arrange dates we're
going to have some champagne and i'm
going to spend a week with each of your
houses doing the financial freedom
challenge we're going to vlog it we're
going to document it it's going to go
viral
of the three financial freedom
challenges
out of the three of you the person i do
gel with the best and gets the best
results over the week
i'm going to up the stakes and i'm going
to spend three years doing a millionaire
challenge
where you're going to be mentored
personally by me and we're going to
spend three years working closely
together and that's going to be the
person that knocks the financial freedom
challenge most out of the park i'm
massively impressed with all three of
you you're amazing
and one of you is the the ultimate
winner of the addiction is going to be
the person that gets i've raised it
it's going to be the person that gets
the millionaire challenge where you're
going to become
you're going to become a property
millionaire in three years but you're
all going to receive the financial
freedom challenge so congratulations
so why don't we go out have some
champagne order some food
and set the dates for the financial
freedom challenges in ireland
in manchester and in london
oh god
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
um
i'm still so speechless but all i can do
is thank everyone they've been brilliant
and this is it this is my new chapter in
life and
there's no stopping me now to say i'm
excited i'm
overwhelmed there's really an
understatement i don't think words can
explain how i feel right now
i feel for the last few years i've been
grafting putting in work been getting no
results
and i feel when you pray to god and you
have an opportunity it comes it might
not come in the package that you
expected
but it comes and now i'm finally seeing
everything i've been praying
everything on my vision but i can now
actually feel it coming to fruition
but realistically he's got no idea what
it really means to me and my family and
my entire family tree
um because it's really going to change
everything i'm going to play
full-heartedly i'm going to play 400
and i'm just super excited for what's to
come and i'm just so grateful again to
be giving an opportunity
how i'm feeling right now is like on top
of
on top of the absolute world like
nothing can tear us down right now like
i feel
amazing i feel relieved when he said
like he'll do the financial freedom
challenge with myself
i was like i just i just felt
overwhelmed
like it's just a massive relief
you know because when i realized getting
into the final like i
like it's this i don't want this like
and i keep saying this because it's so
true like
like this isn't something i want this is
something i need there's a different
level of hunger for it a different
burning sensation that you have inside
and when he said that you'll you'll do
the challenge with myself
and we all won i was just like oh my god
i could not believe it and like even now
like i'm just
still shaking i'm still hot and nervous
from it
but i'm just over the moon absolute
cloud nine
so there we have it folks three
financial freedom
challenges coming up i just had to do
that so they were all so fantastic
so i'm gonna be going to islands i'm
gonna be going to manchester united to
london to help those guys become
financially free and the winner
who performs the best is going to
receive the millionaire challenge over
three years this is just incredible i
also put together a prize draw
for everybody watching the eviction
following and said that the winner of
the prize draw
was going to receive 12 000 pounds worth
of
training between the two of them and the
winner
of the prize draw is sadie g
and ross harley so sadie g ross holly
you've got 24 hours to claim
your prize also in other news some of
the people on the eviction that got
evicted
have now become financially free faz is
now financially free
andrew it's almost financially free
doing multiple deals jamal
is financially free so you're going to
see their winners on a wednesday stories
coming up but i tell you this
you do not need to spend a week with me
doing the financial freedom challenge to
become financially free
this is your year you've got this and
just for watching the eviction i'm
putting on a property investors crash
course that's a
full one day intense program and
if you'd like to attend the crash course
i'm giving it away to everybody
for free so there's a one pound booking
fee just to check that you were a real
person but if you
check the link below book on the
property investors crash course i'm
personally going to be running the
training
it's going to be 12 years of my
knowledge condensed into one day
and you can attend for absolutely free
i'll leave it in the description
thank you so much for watching and god
[Music]
bless
for that